- Don't be hard on yourself
for rebounding when an animal dies.
You know it's not like dating.
You're allowed to try
to replace the thing.
A few years ago I ended up
getting a job in Los Angeles.
We had our cats, Gidget and Enzo.
Gidget's like a sweet, calico cat.
A little thick, but it's all muscle.
Enzo is a gray marbled,
super-affectionate cat.
Within two weeks of being in the apartment
I get a phone call and it's my girlfriend
and she's just sobbing on the phone.
"Enzo's dead."
My girlfriend watched the cat
jump up onto the sill of this window
and Enzo fell nine stories to his death.
I go back home to downtown L.A.
I see my girlfriend
holding a bloody towel.
All the sudden I hear some loud rap music
and it's my friend Jimmy
and he rolls up in a totally
sick convertible Mustang.
Long story short, Jimmy and
I have to sort of figure out
how we can dispose of my
really sweet dead cat.
Downtown Los Angeles has no yards.
Even the park is full of cement.
There is a moment where I'm like,
could I bury it in Griffith Park?
So we look for a vet that can
actually incinerate this body.
We end up finding one
and we show up in the
convertible, top down.
I bring the cat in, and
the vet walks in and says,
"Oh, how's Enzo doing?"
And then I have to sort
of explain to the vet tech
that the cat is in fact
dead inside of the towel.
The vet tech was super helpful
and gave me lots of options.
I could get Enzo's ashes in an urn.
They were very accepting of all
payment types, it turns out.
So I say, can you take
him and incinerate him?
I don't need the ashes, I
don't need anything special.
The vet tech politely takes
Enzo from me in the towel.
As I'm leaving, walking out of the vet,
the vet tech emerges from the back.
"Hey man, like, do you need this towel?"
He's, like, dangling this towel
that has cat blood all over it.
I'm like, no please, no thank
you, leave me alone sir.
Two days later it's the weekend.
My girlfriend and I are grieving.
We go to the desert to find peace.
My girlfriend and I both see
a sign on the side of the road
that says, "Yucca Valley Animal Shelter."
We go to the animal shelter.
They give us two options.
One is this kind of old lady cat,
missing some fur, a little cross-eyed.
And the other cat they show us
is this beautiful orange marbled cat
and it looks exactly like Enzo.
We drove it home and
we named him Loverboy.
And he's been our little
Loverboy ever since.
(cats purring)
(rhythmic music)
(gentle whooshing)
(metal creaking)